[Music]
earlier today President Trump bowed to
his critics and signed an executive
order intended to halt the separation of
illegal immigrant families at the border
now if you really believe the hysteria
of this last week was about keeping
immigrant children with their parents
then you probably assume Democrats are
thrilled about this they got what they
demanded they ought to be celebrating
tonight but they're not they're still
angry
senator Kamla Harris of California
tweeted this quote this executive order
doesn't fix the crisis indefinitely
detaining children with their families
in camps it's inhumane and will not make
us safe meanwhile said a Richard
Blumenthal of Connecticut apparently
dialed into the same talking points call
his response sounded eerily similar to
his colleagues here's what he said quote
indefinitely imprisoning children and
their families is still inhumane and
ineffective law enforcement well by now
you probably realized that like most
debates in Washington this was never
really about what they claimed it was
about they never are the left doesn't
believe that America has the right to
stop poor people from coming over our
southern border under any circumstances
legal or not okay most voters disagree
with that either way it would be nice to
have an honest national debate about all
of this before the midterm elections
that would help everybody that's the
last thing Democrats want though because
they would lose that debate
so rather than habit they're whipping
their supporters into a frenzy of
mindless rage you've seen on cable
television for the last week that is of
course the surest way to short-circuit
rational thinking and conversation and
get people to obey